>> Jon: HEY, THAT'S OUR SHOW!
JOIN US TOMORROW NIGHT AT 11:00.
NOW, I WOULD IMAGINE AS THIS
SHOW IS AIRING, THERE MAY BE
INFORMATION OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW THAT THE AUDIENCE MIGHT NOT
BE AWARE OF, SO I
WILL JUST TELL YOU.
DOUG HERZOG AND MICHELLE
GAINLESS OF COMEDY CENTRAL GAVE
ME AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
17 YEARS AGO TO PILOT
THIS WONDERFUL FRANCHISE.
AND I -- 17 YEARS IS THE LONGEST
I HAVE EVER IN MY LIFE HELD
A JOB BY 16 YEARS AND 5 MONTHS.
(CHEERING)
THANK YOU!
THE UPSHOT THERE BEING, I AM A
TERRIBLE EMPLOYEE.
BUT IN MY HEART, I KNOW, IT IS
TIME FOR SOMEONE ELSE TO HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
NO!
I TOLD YOU THEY DIDN'T KNOW.
YOU PROBABLY KNOW.
NOT RIGHT AWAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE -- YOU KNOW,
WE'RE STILL WORKING OUT DETAILS.
I'M UP IN SEPTEMBER.
MIGHT BE AROUND THEN, MIGHT BE
DECEMBER, MIGHT BE JULY, WE'RE
STILL WORKING OUT DETAILS.
I DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC PLANS.
GOT A LOT OF IDEAS.
I GOT A LOT OF THINGS IN MY
HEAD.
I'M GOING TO HAVE DINNER ON A
SCHOOL NIGHT WITH MY FAMILY, WHO
I HAVE HEARD FROM MULTIPLE
SOURCES ARE LOVELY PEOPLE.
(LAUGHTER)
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT GOING TO BE
HERE AND TRY AND SUM UP WHAT
THIS PLACE HAS MEANT TO ME OVER
THE YEARS, BUT I COULDN'T DO
THAT AND WE HAVE PLENTY OF TIME
AND I'VE GOT A MYRIAD OF PEOPLE
TO THANK AND WE'LL GET TO THAT
OVER TIME.
I'M NOT GOING ANYWHERE TOMORROW.
BUT THIS SHOW DOESN'T DESERVE AN
EVEN SLIGHTLY RESTLESS HOST AND
NEITHER DO YOU.
I DON'T THINK I'M GOING TO MISS
BEING ON TELEVISION EVERY DAY.
I'M GOING TO MISS COMING HERE
EVERY DAY.
AND THIS IS WHERE -- I LOVE THE
PEOPLE HERE.
THEY'RE THE BEST.
THEY'RE CREATIVE AND
COLLABORATIVE AND KIND.
AND THAT'S ALLITERATIVE BUT IT'S
CHEATING BECAUSE IT'S A K,
BUT YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M SAYING.
THEY'RE -- I LOVE THEM AND
RESPECT THEM SO MUCH.
>> WE LOVE YOU, JON!
>> Jon: YEAH!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
ANYWAY!
ARRRRR! WHAT IS THIS FLUID?
WHAT ARE THESE FEELINGS?
FRANKENSTEIN ANGRY!
(APPLAUSE)
IT'S BEEN AN ABSOLUTE PRIVILEGE,
IT'S BEEN THE HONOR OF MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE.
I THANK YOU FOR WATCHING IT, FOR
HATING WATCHING IT.
WHATEVER REASON YOU ARE
TUNING IN FOR, YOU GET IN THIS
BUSINESS WITH THE IDEA THAT
MAYBE YOU HAVE A POINT OF VIEW
AND SOMETHING TO EXPRESS AND TO
RECEIVE FEEDBACK FROM THAT IS
THE GREATEST FEELING YOU COULD
ASK FOR, AND I THANK YOU.